The best advice for bone marrow cancer in the spine that's increasing.
So, I believe the person who asked this question is someone who's got breast cancer that's
the testicized to the bone, so it's not bone marrow cancer.
So understand, if you have metastasis to the bone, it's the same cancer that is now set
up bone somewhere else in your body, so it's still breast cancer that's the testicized
to the bone.
It's that bone cancer, unless you've had a biopsy and you're showing a completely new
type of cancer.
We have some patients that have two different, completely different types of cancer, but
if it's metastasis, it's the same cancer.
Prostate cancer that's the testicized to the bone, it's actually prostate cells that are
growing in the bone, and it's weakened in the bone.
Cancer that metastasis to bone is always illidic, meaning that it's destructive to bone.
So you end up weakening the bone, and if it's a weight-barried bone like the spine or the leg
or the pelvis, then there are certain parts of the pelvis that are weight-barried.
But it's you risk fracture, so you have to do your best on all levels to kill the cancer
in the bone.
That's where radiation can have its shiny moment to kill cancer in the bone, because you
could get more specific, which I have radiation, you're doing all the natural things that you
can do that would kill the cancer, where the primary cancer was, you're doing the same
things to kill in the metastasis.
Now there's other things that you would do to help prevent metastasis, but once metastasis
is already taken place, how do you kill the cancer that's in the bone?
Again, back to the same thing that you're doing to kill the cancer in the primary side.
Now what else could you do if there's body destruction, loss of bone density?
Then you're looking at doing things to increase bone density, which to be the number one,
the literally the only supplement that I would recommend to increase bone density is the
product called osteo-k, osteo-k, as in vitamin K, because it has MK4 at high levels, because
if you want a really good calcium in the bone, you have to use MK4.MK7, which is good to get
to absorb calcium and absorb vitamin D at MK4 is the only thing that will get calcium
into the bone.
And if you have bone loss, whether it's osteoporosis, osteopedia, or a metastatic cancer to the
bone, with lidic lesions and bone loss, you have to use MK4 at very high doses, and that
osteo-k is the literally the only product of the market that has the dose level that you
need.
That's super expensive or anything, but osteo-k, we have a number of people on.